rave reviews
YouTube's favorite show everybody meme
review wipe it up everybody it's time
for another episode what is he going to
say about memes this week I don't know
it's so exciting
yes it is thank you unfortunately I have
terrible news I'm gonna give you guys
some warning to click away this video
right now I know you're not gonna though
you slimy little scumbag II like you've
got anything better than to you I know
why you clicked on this that's why I
called you slimy I know that you know
that I already know that you know okay
you're just here for some baozi aren't
you you you nasty I like that though I
like that bow Saint hashtag bow sick
it's taking over the world it's taken
over the planet is taking over the
universe when our planet cease to exist
the one thing that will keep on living
is bow zette aliens will find scatters
of our artifacts and it will be written
upon it foul Saint and that's all we
really need to transpire across the
universe hail the Queen bow set what is
about setting yes of course it's in the
name it's the female version of Bowser
we have officially done it boys if I
said hashtag was trending worldwide in
Japan bow set has been on has been going
on for a while but this is the tweet
that started it all by honey one it's a
wedding
peach says no Mario is Super Saiyan
Bowser is super safe but then they look
at each other and oh my god Bowser
became bow sit and they smash I added
the last part sorry
Aloha This Is It this is all it takes to
break the internet people posted this
hashtag I mean you can't go online
without seeing bow set somewhere you
just can't did browser lose weight
is it hot in here or is it just me
because the powerset is looking very
attractive
sorry mice yeah I just feel like I want
to be honest mr. Miyamoto so how are the
fans enjoying the upcoming game in the
switch games
Reggie everyone seems to be talking
about NS bu and the super crown Miyamoto
ah yes now people can play a speech
hooray
it seems like it's for a different
reason just look at Bowser
look what they did look what they did
mr. Miyamoto a close-up of my eyes
peach is screaming internally of all the
bow set fan fan fiction it's like it's
anyone that has a pencil on a paper has
decided yes
yes I am going to draw a bow set what
else am I going to do with my life I
don't get it
like I feel like this whole thing is a
sexy Phil clickbait title people are
freaking out over power sir and here's
why I still don't get it I still don't
get it hey look it's a BOGO cat bad day
at some point we have to just be
responsible perhaps we were all just
ignorant perhaps we were all just blind
bow set has been in front of us since
the very beginning
anyway thing could be bow saying oh my
god I see it now bow set is incredibly
attractive how could I have been so
blind okay we definitely can't show this
okay obviously this meme is still
blowing up
there's not really a much of important
for me to rate it but simply makes me
physically ill and attractive at the
same time I'm gonna have to give it a
fight oh it's a perfect balance means
whoop next vein intermission is that
what it's called just wanna point out
okay Bongo cat still do it strong still
going strong everybody
songul cat is doing great thank you for
asking
[Music]
so while you waste your time with stupid
Bowser
just know there are positive sites out
there there are positive movements this
is not really much of a mean it's more
of a meme war that I feel I have to
acknowledge we got the m14 gang versus
the Olimpia gang in black ops zombies
whatever it's cold I'm not a nerd I
don't play video games
I'm not some loser especially that plays
Call of Duty how's it going brothers man
is made by m14 game imagine on
ironically using the m14 made by Olympia
gang ouch that one's gotta really hurt
we all know that the m14 is superior
anyone that picks a shotgun in any video
game is just a that can't aim
properly stupid the m14 takes skill it
takes accuracy and you know what it
doesn't matter when the dogs come yes
there will be bears technically superior
for that moment triggering speed with
your finger which of course any 114 gang
all the way transit bus driver B like
this poster I mean you think I'm gonna
let you bum on my bus with that Olympia
in your hands this is epic guys this
post was made by m14 gang and I approve
this message
now of course I will pass on the
question to you guys are you part of the
m14 gang or the Olympia game just
passing the question on to you guys let
me know in the comments down below I
really want to hear what you think and
not just get more comments on my video
passing it on to you guys you have to be
probably one of the dumbest people on
the planet to pick in the Olympia but
what do you think passing the question
on to you guys let me know down below
[Music]
apparently the goal here is just to
destroy everything Nintendo related from
my from my positive memory of a
childhood that is English apparently
stop ruining old things Nintendo just
stop next
meme everybody commit you're scared a
minute to appreciate me review and all
it's done for everyone has it made your
life better
probably not but smash like if you're
enjoying this episode actually smash
like regardless last meme of the week
everybody
Netflix adaptation mean we have the
manga very nice we have the anime oh
it's pretty good
Netflix adaptation wow you make me sick
get you out of here he's fat and ugly
the manga whoa the anime wow that's
pretty accurate they did a great job
Netflix adaptation manga hey look is
Maria Annie Mae wow that looks really
accurate Netflix adaptation I don't know
why Netflix is so keen
just murdering or every anime ever I
will never forgive you Netflix for what
you did to Yagami like why are we still
here
just suffered
I never forget never forget never forget
never forget screw you Netflix manga I
goddamnit
manga anime Netflix you know what I'm
gonna go on I'm gonna go on a limb here
and say that the anime is the best you
know we won't live long but it's one of
those memes that will just and it will
live here
it would live here I'm gonna give it a 4
point 9 me review everybody YouTube show
thank you guys so much for watching
leave a like if you enjoyed subscribe if
you aren't so we can stop teach series
and I'll see you guys tomorrow with
another video bruh fast
[Music]